[Musique]
hier c'est 8 créé l'événement avec le
retour sur son antenne du mythique jeu à
prendre ou à laisser
et dès les premières secondes de
l'émission cyril est visiblement déjà
comme à la maison
[Applaudissements]
la presse avait parlé de l'événement
comme télé loisirs qui a interviewé baba
avant la grande première ce sera
évidemment un autre style que julien
courbet mais j'adore jouer sur ce côté
suspense et une mécanique qui rend fou
s'il n'a pas fait sa fameuse tête de
suspense la tension était tout de même
au rendez vous et pour la toute première
partie sandrine alias eva longoria a
remporté la somme de 10000 euros
enfin côté audience le jeu attire et 919
me téléspectateurs avec une pointe à
plus d'un million trois cent mille
téléspectateurs une très belle
performance qui prouve que tout le monde
a besoin de se défendre en ce moment
[Musique]
une prestation qui a également convaincu
julien courbet qui sur les réseaux
sociaux a félicité son successeur
j'ai pas pu regarder mais vu les
commentaires le retour d'à prendre ou à
laisser et une réussite bravo cyril
hanouna retour d'à prendre ou à laisser
en direct ce soir dès 20h15 alors et ya
pas mal de gens qui disent il faut
qu'ils changent de t-shirts le pauvre
mushkin jean pascal ne vous inquiétez
pas il fait très très chaud sur le
plateau allez on y va apprendre à les
cct tiers sachez que vraiment je
voudrais vous remercier pour tous vos
messages
j'ai jamais eu autant de messages
positifs sur une émission c'était
incroyable franchement incroyable
alors c'est vrai que j'ai succédé à
arthur et à julien courbet à la
présentation d'à prendre ou à laisser
donc regarder et c'est vrai que c'était
pas évident surtout julien regarder ça
va arriver
[Applaudissements]
vous jouez vous savez quoi je vous aime
vous avez le nom de mettre l'ambiance
c'est habillée comme ça qu'on les lit
gens sincères avec ça non mais j'ai
profité coup de désinfectant ne
paraissait pas mais il est devenu
complètement fou il s'est pas assagie
depuis l'époque nature la partie que
soit votre petite chorégraphie que je me
régale
oui j'ai encore à d'y être ce soir un
vraiment je vous le dis je suis très
très chaud pendant le week end
et ben moi j'ai été complètement fan je
suis ravi de cette émission et je me
suis juste éclaté on attendait à chaque
fois la boîte suivante on était comme
des oufs je les regarde avec des copines
est ce que je me suis dit c'est que les
gens qui vous aiment pas d'habitude et
bien là on vous trouve son séjour alors
là il ya des frais je me suis dit qu'en
regardant cette émission vous étiez
harper impartiale vous étiez classe vous
étiez en fait vous étiez ce que vous
êtes dans la vie est ce que vous essayez
de cacher dans d'autres émissions
pourquoi il est là je vous ai trouvé
vous bienveillant avec les candidats le
casting est génial quartier génial c'est
mon personnage a bien travaillé voir ce
soir est reconnaître leur vie enfin moi
j'ai été complètement fan de a à z
un petit bémol parce que j'ai mis 9
j'aurais pu mettre 10 mai vous n'avez
pas écouté votre styliste et vous
l'écoutez souvent et cette fois-ci vous
l'avez pas écouté la veste ça n'allait
pas du tout on aurait dit arthur a beau
arthur avec ça ouais le dain comme ça le
nid du cac c'est vrai que arthur on aime
bien aime bien le début mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai d'ailleurs on l'appelle najim
du piquant dans le pays il avait alors
moi j'ai adoré l'émission je vais vous
dire que c'est de la merde en barre pour
algérie c'est de la merde c'est ce
qu'assure verrez ça je vous dis c'est
regarder mon mari qui arrêtait pas de
faire des des prospectives et qui
jacques tu es tout le temps mais sinon
moi j'ai adoré le jeu je ne pourrai
jamais candidate à ça je suis trop
distraite tue pas c'est comme si vous a
demandé ce soir j'aurais bien aimé être
capable d'un enfant dans ce pays était
formidable aptitudes spéciales
la fille était formidable mais vraiment
aucun et mais moi ce qui m'a le plus et
bat hiller d'abord vous êtes un [ __ ]
de comédiens [ __ ] de menteur moi je
rencontrais pas tranquille le travail
vous rend la vie plus comme en plus on
perd bien mais vraiment c'est le métier
on voit ça et en plus surtout c'est du
direct
et moi j'ai été mais émerveillé que
c'est rouler aussi bien et que c'est
rouler sous ce ciel cadré du début à la
fin que mon mari était persuadé que
c'était enregistré m'a dit quand est-ce
qu'ils ont enregistré s'agit du même nom
c'est du direct
cedrino formidable isabelle tu dis que
vous montez pas ce que tu sous-entends
qu'ils connaissent
dans les boîtes et du coup ils
influencent je ne sais pas ce qui est en
jeu c'est pas du tout évoqué un mentor
de tout ça c'est parce que mes critères
aussi non mais le banquier mais j'ai
vraiment un banquier au téléphone ya
plein de gens qui m'ont posé cette
question aussi j'ai vraiment une
personne de téléphone et sachez que en
plus je vous le dis elle m'insulte
souvent en fait t'as vraiment ouais hein
il m'insulte tu m'insultes en arabe et
toubon qui il fracasse et c'est vrai
qu'il me donne la somme à chaque fois et
je vous dis non non j'ai un vrai bond
qui au téléphone à madame à la lèvre
vous m'apprenez un truc m'a fait penser
bleus au procès que choisit du mythe ou
voit les noms j'ai vraiment banquiers si
c'est pas du tout madame bien sûr il ya
vraiment un banquier il donne les samoa
je peux pas choisir dix ans et ben voilà
ben aperçu main thierry jean pascal marc
cherry pour son arrivée à manger j'ai
trouvé l'émission très très bien et
bravo jean pascal même mais adario tu
peux me défoncer natation j'ai pas fini
moi je vais vite parce que je pense que
l'émission elle peut encore progresser
parce que moi je trouve ça manquait un
peu plus de conneries venant de toi je
vous fait rire et c'est juste un petit
peu plus drôle est ce que j'ai trouvé
génial c'est qu'on est quand même encore
le seul l'huissier puisque je crois que
tu es de même à la star ac 130 accroît
les serviles et je ne savais pas que
sera pas se marier avec un n'hésite pas
il ne vieillit pas incroyable il ne
bouge pas ce mec-là gens me voyez moi
j'ai adoré mais de façon je l'attendais
cette émission là et même si ça ont été
présentés par quelqu'un d'autre j'aurais
adoré aussi je dis franchement ce que
c'est la mécanique du jeu je pose c'est
une très très fort et voilà et il faut
aller vers un matin surtout de le faire
en direct parce que je sais pas comment
on fait pour gérer le time i pour
arriver enfin la dernière boîte à 9h15
c'est exceptionnel pour moi d'ailleurs
je me suis posé une question si elle
accepte l'offre du banquier à 8h30 vous
fait quoi exactement mais non mais ça
alors je vous dirai pas très bonne
question jean michel si elle accepte of
books de vernis déjà on revoit les
autres boîtes et il ya un nouveau truc
dans le jeu c'est le come back
c'est à dire qu'elle peut lever de boîte
et on peut lui proposer le banquet paul
a rappelé lui dire voilà vous avez
enlevé deux petites boîtes
est ce que vous voulez revenir dans le
jeu faire un come back avec les boîtes
qui reste elle est donc là vous désirez
que le jeu voilà c'est ça et ça ça peut
être très fort s'il ya un come back un
jour et c'est énorme
et puis vous avez trouvé a eu beaucoup
de chance et ça a de la chance il en
faut surtout quand un animateur la caq a
dit à certains niveaux de compétence le
manque de chance une foule pro b seul et
vous avez toujours cette chance et de la
fin de rêve d'arriver que moi daddy
mines une boîte à son idée le cas et ça
c'est énorme ça fait et c'était le
timing le sucre et en syrie alors il ya
des petites gens aussi qui m'ont demandé
pourquoi d'apple échange de bois tiers
alors j'ai demandé à la productrice
voilà et qui est la productrice
historique 1,2 à prendre ou à laisser
qui étaient là hier soir et madinah pas
toujours les changes de boîtes pas comme
elle m'a dit c'est possible qu'ils
échangent de boîte ce soir qu'il y ait
les changes de boîtes dans à prendre ou
à laisser on dirait que je ne sais même
pas avec qui je vais jouer ce avec quoi
ils ne veulent rien me dire je ne suis
au courant de rien oui maxime je me suis
bien amusé plus l'émission avançait plus
on rentrait dedans mais en plus de ça
c'était le plaisir de retrouver un vrai
décor de jeter les mêmes la réalisation
elle était être en gros les zooms et
panoramique or c'est peut-être un détail
mais c'est très important pour ce type
de format et concèdent en l'incarnant au
départ très concentré vous êtes lâchés
au fil du programme
s'il y avait un petit bémol parce qu'on
se dit tout il ya peut-être un manque de
tension sur le riz bile sur les deux
dernières boîtes c'est mon avis si non
respect du format belle dynamique et
incarnation parfaite vraiment peut-être
tap le regard des taux par mois j'ai pu
le regarder après en replay parce que je
remercie directement et chuté sur la
route mais je vais le découper en deux
parties et je vous avais dit ça va être
un vrai challenge et je vais vous dire
ce que je pense vraiment pour de vrai la
première partie c'est alors avec ses
gestes barrières tu perds le côté un peu
on va danser comme c'était
historiquement avait cartonné que tu
danses tu perds le côté ce que j'ai pas
aimé c'est les boîtes ou qu'on peut pas
échanger des boîtes donc je me crois que
c'est un raisons sanitaires non on peut
le faire si c'est pareil on va le faire
c'est extraordinaire parce qu'à un
moment donné il ya une boîte à 250
milles j'aurais bien voulu qu'on propose
à la dame de changer sa boîte la boîte
de marion je pense à mauléon du monde de
changer sa boîte
est ce que j'ai pas aimé aussi sa salle
est parti j'ai pas aimé c'est le
banquier moi j'ai des souvenirs que le
téléphone sonnait tout seul et là vous
avez annoncé le bon pied du coup ça m'a
un peu coupé les pattes parce qu'en plus
vous faites la vanne derrière en disant
tu es content un banquier
j'aurais préféré que ce soit le banquier
à 250 milles de téléphone se déclenche
tout seul pour la perversité tué 250
milles ça c'est lé point que jésus suis
dit bon c'est un peu trop maintenant les
points que j'adorais c'est une émission
en direct ça veut dire que tu peux pas
me tenir
tu peux pas tenir les gens il ya des
gens qui viennent à la télé pour faire
les intéressants pour se croire marc ont
donc tu ne peux pas les tenir ça j'ai
adoré parce que parfois il ya des vannes
qui ont été faites et c'est là que je
rejoins kelly sur la bienveillance avec
nous nous c'est normal vous de
chroniqueurs quand on fait des vannes
boum ça charrie derrière vous avez été
d'une bienveillance avec les gens que
qui a été extraordinaire c'est à dire
que vous avez été gentil avec eux tout
le temps et moi j'ai bien aimé cette
émission pour ça parce qu'il ya de la
bienveillance la mécanique jeu l'adorent
bon voila c'était une première
j'attends de voir la deuxième la
troisième je pense que ça va prendre son
rythme j'ai mis un set alors aux moyens
non je vous dit rien il ya peu il ya eu
plein de tweets vraiment exceptionnel et
il ya même eu un petit message de
soutien courbet qui l'a dit je n'ai pas
pu regarder mais vu les commentaires
le retour de la prendre à l'essai
officielle est une réussite bravo cyril
hanouna et ce n'est que la première
balle merci à julien courbet toujours la
classe notre julien que j'aime fort et
voilà et j'espère voilà qui tue un jour
j'aimerais bien qu'il vienne jouer avec
moi un jour sur les blogs réunion
puisqu'on fera 10 travers elle bien
entendu avec des people c'est vraiment
pas évident parce qu'il n'y avait pas ce
côté contact on se souvient d'arthur qui
venait qui masse et les contres il est
candidat
sans ça nous avons réussi à faire un
truc fort quand même même avec les
gestes barrière même avec des gens qui
ont des plexi comme ça donc ça moi j'ai
bien kiffé et un truc que je voulais
vous demander en direct là on a vu
julien courbet vous a fait un compliment
oui est-ce que vous avez un compliment
avant l'émission d'arthur ou même après
félicitations parce que c'est son bébé
quand est-ce que vous en voyez
interceptions n'a pas de mobile et la
pana il n'a plus d'argent
vous avez n'y a pas de robin des bois
non j'ai pas des choses ne fait pas
d'eux adam avant bonne chance au coureur
parce que ça sans émission quand même
non je pense que c'est normal sur emi
sur soi sur ses missions mais c'est lui
qui l'a mis à l'antenne et même après
l'émission y'a pas eu à brême après même
avant et pendant et non à mon cas - qui
c'était le bon qui peut-être m'en suis
pas rendu l'arrêt shihri merci alors le
retour à prendre ou à laisser j'aime 62%
j'aime pas 38 samba merci c'est comme
jean pascal en fait je crois que c'est
le même sondage à chaque fois avec les
mêmes chiffres
je vais vous dire je crois qu'ils se
sont arrêtés sur ça déchire ils se sont
arrêtés sur sa wii et je peux poser une
dernière qui suit bien sûr elle était
persuadée que vous alliez déborder vu
comme c'était c'était parti est-ce que
c'est prévu que rien plus ou moins 10
minutes si c'est vraiment il ya une
tension a tourné en cantonais en direct
on fait ce qu'on veut je vous dire après
c'est ça vous dois ça nous de voir le
tag minorisées oui voilà mais après
après la fraîcheur et que timing était
parfait hier à ben c'est pas s'il va
être parfait au nord est aujourd'hui en
plus après juste après sur un film avec
michel piccoli hommage à michel à la
volée voilà où sera long sera la seule
chaîne à le faire ce soir avec un film
exceptionnel et valérie question là pour
c'est l'avis du public
et ben moi j'ai passé un super moment
franchement toutes les missions très
sympathique plateau est magnifique et
ouais vraiment
design l'ambiance les candidats j'espère
toujours un jour avec nous franchement
j'ai adoré je te fais un gros bisou qui
lui ce soir juste après bien sûr 20h15
est ce que vous vous avez vraiment pas
ce que vous en avez fait plein des
émissions en direct vous savez ce que ça
il ya des émissions qui vous font kiffer
et d'autres ou du doigt certaines
émissions comme une autre a été bien au
bape amiens est ce que vous avez qui
fait hier vraiment j'ai kiffé léger j'ai
hâte d'y être ce soir parce que je joue
vraiment à bas ces choix fou vous avez
vous vraiment sincèrement vous avez le
trac ou pas franchement rock mozart
ultra convoité un nouveau format
prochain bah non parce qu'en fait qu'on
a été cette émission avons donc en fait
c'était l'enchaînement en fait comme
c'était pas la première émission de la
journée on a effectué le matin j'avais
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de trac quand je
fais c'est que du kif tous les jours
quelques galères avec des pontes de
l'audiovisuel tous les soirs alors et de
fréquenter la crème de la crème
donc je peux vous dire c'est là que je
suis pas bien vraiment dire que font pas
les autres par exemple les autres quand
il présente une émission un jeu ou quoi
que ce soit il arrive et son frère ils
sont dans l'âge il se concentre que sur
l'eau sur leur jeu vous vous sortez de
là deux minutes après vous êtes en
direct est ce que ce serait pas mieux
d'arrêter c'est que du kif et de faire
que les boîtes non non non je dis ce que
je pense moi je dis ce que je pense bien
parce que c'est que des infections
robert ma vie c'est que de tous les
temps record d'hier et vous voulez
vraiment que jean michel maire
représente ce que ce sera bien sûr il
serait très bon jour michel d'ailleurs
je l'aï mis à la présentation au moment
de tmp
il avait été excellent